I think people have to be very careful to not
get trapped along the way with things that you
can afford with your current lifestyle like the
way you're living and the way you're earning but
they're also imprisoning you in the fact that you
are now going to have to work this 40-hour week
job in order to get this thing that you can't
afford but now you're saddled down to this job
you've no you're not saving you're not you're not
putting things in a good place and you're working
for these things working for things as rewards
is a real trap that a lot of people fall into
it's the biggest one you know that's even telev
also says that uh you know there are two great
addictions heroin and a monthly salary right and
and that's why you can't get rich renting out your
time because even when you start charging more
and more for your time it's a slow upgrade Loop
and then you upgrade your house at the same time
and open your car at the same time you move in the
neighborhood you really also have to get used to
ignoring your peers or upgrading or changing the
definition of your peers a lot of people here who
are poor here but they would be rich if they were
living in Thailand and Bali and if they have
the luxury of a remotely doable job they may
want to be living there and saving up money but
the ignoring the peers is an issue because the
Keeping Up With the Jones is a real phenomenon
yeah Envy makes the world go around right yeah
and then there's a there's a other thing that
people have to avoid even allowing their mind
to think when they're hearing what you're saying
and all this logical fantastic advice there's
these six dirty words that's easy for you to say
yeah that is a terrible trap I mean look I grew up
as a first generation immigrant uh in Jamaica
Queens uh with zero money single mom two kids
working day and night going to school uh you know
I wash dishes uh I was K I was working catering
jobs I was mowing lawns I was working since the
age of 11 on and off here and there um didn't
have two cents to rub together you know I had
to borrow 400 to go to college like literally
a short four hundred dollars 400 I had to find 400
I didn't have it you know got rejected from a job
at Dunkin Donuts so like okay it's not to say
that it's easy it's not easy it's not actually
really freaking in heart it is the hardest thing
you will do but it's also the rewarding thing you
know look at the kids who are born rich no meaning
to their lives you're a terrible Place yeah your
real your real resume is just a cataloging of
all your suffering right if I were to ask you to
describe your real life to yourself when you look
back in your deathbed you're going to go back and
say what are the interesting things I've done
and it's all going to be around the sacrifices
that you've made and the hard things that you did
anything you're given doesn't matter you know you
you have your four limbs you have your brain you
have your head you have your skin that's all for
granted so you have to do hard things anyway to
create your own meaning in life um making money is
a fine one yeah struggle it is hard I'm not going
to say it's easy it's a really hard but the tools
are all available it's all there there's also
these these traps that people sort of establish
in their own mind of giving themselves excuses
or giving themselves in unsurmountable obstacles
insurmountable paths to victim mentality yeah yeah
it's somebody else's fault it's my skin color's
fault it's the system's fault yeah those people
are sinking I feel bad for them I want to shake
them out of it and say actually you can get out of
it you just have to stop thinking it's everybody
you have to alter the perspective yeah but it's
so difficult for people to do it's one of the most
difficult things for people to do is to change
the way they approach approach reality itself
at the end of the day I I do think even despite
what I said earlier life is really a single player
game it's all going on in your head you know
whatever you think you believe will very much
shape your reality both from what risks you take
and what actions you perform but also just your
everyday experience of reality if you're walking
down the street and you're judging everyone you're
like I don't like that person because their
skin color I don't like that oh she's she's not
attractive that guy's fat this person's a loser
oh who put this in my way uh you know the more
you judge the more you're gonna separate yourself
and you'll feel good for an instant because you'll
feel good about yourself I'm better than that but
then you're gonna feel lonely and then you're just
gonna see negativity everywhere the world just
reflects your own feelings back at you reality
is neutral the reality has no judgments to a
tree there's no concept of right or wrong or
good or bad right you're born you have a whole
set of sensory experiences and stimulations and
lights and colors and sounds and then you die yeah
and how you choose to interpret that is up to you
you do have that choice so this is what I meant
that happiness is a choice if you believe it's
the choice then you can start working on it and
I can't tell you how to find it because it's your
own conditionings that are making you unhappy so
you have to uncondition yourself it's just like I
can't fix your eating habits for you can give you
some general guidelines but you got to go through
the hard habit forming of How to Eat Right but you
have to believe it's possible and it is absolutely
possible I was miserable I'm happy as a clam it's
not just the money I got there before the money
Peter Thiel talks a lot about how competition is
besides the point it's counterproductive we're
highly memetic creatures we copy what everybody
else is doing around us we copy our desires from
them everyone around me is a great artist I want
to be an artist if everyone around me is a great
business person I want to be a business person
everybody around me is a social activist I want to
be a social activist that's where my self-esteem
will come from you have to be a little careful
when you get caught up in these status games that
you end up competing over things that aren't worth
competing over so Peter Thiel talks about how he
was going to be a law clerk because he was in law
school and everybody around him wanted to be a law
clerk for a Supreme Court Justice or some famous
judge and he got rejected and that's what made him
go into business so it helped him break out of a
lesser game into a greater game so sometimes you
just get trapped in the wrong game because you're
competing and the best way to escape competition
to get away from the Specter of competition which
is not just stressful and nerve-wracking but will
often drive you to just the wrong answer the way
to Escape competition is to just be authentic
to yourself if you are fundamentally building
and marketing something that is just an extension
of who you are no one can compete with you on that
but when people look at particularly social media
let's bring back to that when you see someone who
you know you see them posed in front of their
mansion with their beautiful car and they're
leaning against it with their designer clothes
on their expensive watch you go ah I want that
right that's what I want what you really want is
freedom you want freedom from your money problems
right and I think that's okay so people once
someone can solve their money problems either
by lowering their lifestyle or by making enough
money and you know essentially what you want to
get everybody to is retirement but not retirement
in the I'm 65 years old sitting in a nursing home
collecting a check retirement different definition
retirement is when you stop sacrificing today for
some imaginary tomorrow okay yes when today is
complete in and of itself you're retired yeah
and so how do you get there well one is you can
have so much money saved up that just your passive
income off of that without your having to lift a
finger covers your burn rate keep your burn rate
low right a second is you just drive your burn
rate down to zero you become a monk a third is
you're doing something you love you enjoy it so
much it's not about the money right so there are
multiple ways to that path but the most common
is people just say I need to make more money and
the kind of wealth creation that I talk about is
about creating Timeless principles and adapting
yourselves that making money won't be an issue
anybody who's read your life you're a testament
to the idea that to not be a victim but to be a
Survivor and it's an attitude that has helped me
in my short life so far could you perhaps expand
on that idea how it's helped you and how that is
perhaps one of the greatest ways to live your
life out regardless of what happens of course
feeling like it's really interesting to make
change some people are victimized by other people
and if it weren't for the ending nation that
that causes we wouldn't have reforms that we need
but that truth is mixed with another very
counterproductive or an individual to feel like
a victim even if he is best attitude is just to be
careful about everything and keep plugging along
and therefore I don't like politicians that
get ahead by trying to make everybody else
feel like a victim yeah they make my flesh
crawl and I just don't believe in it of course
who wants to be a victim instead of a survivor
of course we want and but feeling like a victim
you can recognize your position as bad and try
and improve it that's okay but to have a deep
feeling of the wooden that's all somebody else's
fault is a very counterproductive Way To Think
people aren't even like being around it it's
really stupid and yet our politicians build on
it and make their careers work by doing something
that's very bad for all what people are talking to
and they think they're doing the world's work you
know it's crazy it's absolutely crazy reflections
working for things as rewards the things you
own end up owning you Chuck palahnuk the goal
isn't passive income the goal is active income
doing what you like sahil Lavinia I recommend
watching the video that by Kapil Gupta which
Naval recently shared on Twitter you can check
the link at the top right corner of the
screen the victim mentality my formula for
greatness is amorphati that one wants nothing to
be different not forward not backwards not in all
eternity not merely bear what is necessary still
less conceal it but love it. Nietzsche. A great
man is hard on himself a small man is hard on
others Confucius the competition trap if you have
a guaranteed Market of one I.E yourself you are
ahead of 99 of all entrepreneurs out there team
in fairies ideas don't come out fully formed they
only become clearer as you work on them you just
have to get started Mark Zuckerberg something that
has been useful to me is this idea of building
something that I myself would love to consume even
if I see other entrepreneurs already executing on
that same concept I just do something similar or
shamelessly copycat them if they have better ideas
this might look like I'm getting into competition
instead of escaping from it but the thing is that
as I execute the project I naturally give it
my own spin over time so when I just start the
project my idea it's also just starting it is far
from being a complete business idea but as I work
on the project the idea gets more and more formed
and as it gets formed you're slowly getting away
from competition until the ideal scenario in which
there is demand for your product and the market
cannot find it anywhere where else other than
through you that's the point where you become a
personal Monopoly as one of my favorite writers
David Pearl would put it thanks for watching